il est lu table pour lézan évitable pour
les autres la possibilité d'une deuxième
vague de l'épidémie de coronavirus ne
fait pas consensus
un seul point d'accord par mais les
chercheurs et scientifiques
la circulation du virus ralenti
l'épidémie prospère désormais de manière
lente est endémique
c'est à dire que le virus est chez nous
et il fait des petits progrès qui sont
inéluctables avec le rétablissement de
la plupart des activités humaines
une reprise d'activité qui pourrait
expliquer l'apparition de clusters ici
ou là en allemagne en corée du sud ou
encore en chine mais qui reste
circonscrit à des petites zones
l'épidémie redémarre aussi longs des
pays qui étaient jusqu'à présent peu
touchée
c'est le cas en inde avec près de 700
mille cas recensés pour plus d'1 3
milliard d'habitants l'inde est
désormais le troisième pays le plus
touché au monde en termes de
contamination d'autres pays comme
l'australie madagascar ou encore
l'afrique du sud font face à une
résurgence de l'épidémie une reprise
dans ces pays de l'hémisphère sud
actuellement en période hivernale qui
pourrait suggérer une saisonnalité du
virus à l'instar de la grippe
et si cette saisonnalité se confirmait
on pourrait craindre un re démarrage de
l'épidémie dont les nids sert nord
lorsque les températures commenceront à
baisser
autre argument des scientifiques qui
croient à une seconde vague inévitable
la capacité du virus à se réactiver et à
se déclarer chez une personne déjà guéri
un virologue du centre national espagnol
de biotechnologie a ainsi estimé qu'au
moins 14 % des patients dont le test de
dépistage de covin 19 s'étaient révélés
négatifs était finalement revenu positif
face à ces prévisions pessimistes
d'autres scientifiques font preuve d'une
plus grande prudence voire même de
scepticisme actuellement on ne voit une
deuxième vague dans aucun pays du monde
seulement des cas sporadiques et des
réimportations issue de la phase
pandémique actuelle de nombreuses
données inconnues demeurent concernant
ce virus l'environnement existant au
moment où il s'est propagé n'est plus le
même aujourd'hui
pour ces spécialistes il n'y aurait donc
pas de deuxième vague mais tout
simplement une progression de l'épidémie
dont les zones encore peu touchées et où
on observe avant tout des cas emporté
comme en corée du sud
certains vont même plus loin
on signalons que d'autres virus pourrait
nous immuniser contre le coc vides sont
même avoir été infectés par celui ci
c'est le principe de l'immunité croisé
l'immunité croisé protège votre
organisme contre un virus quand il a été
exposé à un autre virus dans le passé
par exemple si vous avez été infecté par
un coronavirus bénin comme un simple
rhume l'an passé vous pourriez avoir
produit des cellules ou des anticorps
qui vous protège contre le coronavirus
actuel en attendant que les
scientifiques se mettent d'accord le
message du nouveau gouvernement castex
et tombe peut plus clair il faut se
tenir prêt en cas de deuxième vague la
ministre délégué à l'industrie agnès
pannier rue nash et à d'ailleurs indiqué
que les entreprises françaises seraient
incités à acheter des stocks de masques
pour l'ensemble de leurs salariés et ce
pour couvrir une période de dix semaines
au lendemain de cette annonce le titre
du groupe chargeurs qui est avec sa
branche lainière sentais lent des
principaux producteurs de masques
tricolore a vu son titre en bourse gagné
3,7 points
la prudence affichée par le gouvernement
ne devrait donc pas faire que des
mécontents